in this project we're going to be
covering atmospheric scattering which is
the next natural step in this series on
3d world generation so what this will
help with is when we're looking around
at our planets we get this nice sky and
if we move off planet we get this slick
transition from ground view to space
view and it's all seamless now just to
recap in this 3d world generation series
we've covered quite a bit and starting
from a basic mesh generation and height
maps to entire worlds and some more
advanced texturing techniques today
we're working on improving the visuals a
bit with atmospheric scattering and
we'll cover a few ways to do this now
when you see a lot of major engines
doing atmospheric scattering often
they're physically based models that try
to approximate how light scatters
through the atmosphere these are
complicated models based off from real
physics and so they look good but
they're difficult to implement and
difficult to control or you can go the
other way and fake your way through
things will do both we'll cover how
those fancy atmospheric scattering
models work and we'll call put together
a bunch of hacks that kind of look nice
and give a scattering like look you can
decide whether you want alter realism
for your project or the flexibility that
rolling your own shader can give
beginning with physically-based
atmospheric scattering now there's been
a lot of Papers written on the subject
but the cornerstone one there's this one
display of the earth taking into account
atmospheric scattering and really a lot
of newer stuff is just figuring out ways
to make it fast using pre computed
values and look-up tables if we start
skimming over this thing it's kind of
complicated
like really complicated code itself is
actually really simple once you
translate all this crazy math talk to
shader codes there's a couple types of
scattering in these models Rayleigh and
mie scattering Rayleigh scattering is
that scattering from tiny particles in
the atmosphere it's actually what's
responsible for the blue sky you see
outside since some waves links the
shorter ones specifically are scattered
much more strongly than longer ones mie
scattering is similar except while
Rayleigh scattering dealt with tiny
particles like really really small
smaller than the wavelength of light mie
scattering on the other hand deals with
big crap floating in the air so rain
smoke dust pollution
whatever that's what mie scattering is
all about now remember that a planet is
just a solid sphere with a bunch of gas
forming a second sphere around it and as
you get closer to the ground the density
of the atmosphere changes which is why
you're comfortable breathing at sea
level but you need to bring oxygen with
you when you go to the top of Mount
Everest what you're doing is looking out
into direction and you want to figure
out how much light is reaching your eye
and you know is that the density of the
atmosphere changes depending on your
height and their light scatters around
based on particle size and where the Sun
is so roughly if you're looking in a
direction then for every point along
that path you've got to go look in the
direction of the light and do a second
look up on the second path and for every
point along that path you've got to
figure out how much light is being
transmitted and all that and boiling
down to a couple of nested for-loops you
can see here in the shader that the
first loop here is in the direction of
the primary ray or the view direction
and then there's a second loop that goes
in the direction of the Sun and in each
point we figure out the height off the
ground sum up the optical depth and then
accumulate the scattering at that point
and that gives us a nice physically
accurate sky model that you can kind of
just plug in and work with
now if physically accurate isn't what
you're after you can get pretty far just
by piling a bunch of hacks together that
roughly looks right and isn't complex to
implement or change here I've got my
fake atmospheric scattering shader and I
can enter and exit the atmosphere rotate
around the planet see the Sun and make a
sort of nice scattering effect around
the side and that's all just a bunch of
simple effects piled together we'll walk
through it bit by bit so here's our
basic planet I'll just use a gray sphere
to begin with so right now all we have
this grey sphere floating in space if
you look at a picture of the earth it
has this nice little glow around it that
we'd like to reproduce so what we'll do
here in the shader code is figure out
the intersection of the view direction
and the atmosphere and from that we can
look at how high we are off the ground
and then normalize that by the
atmosphere thickness this allows us to
composite a ring around the planet so
now we have this nice little glow or
the earth notice though that our ring
completely surrounds the planet but with
earth it kind of follows where the Sun
is so in code we'll just use the dot
product between the Sun and the normal
to mix from blue to a dark yellow for a
faint glow on the other side and we'll
use this cool rap technique which is
just a little trick to approximate
subsurface scattering and what that'll
do is wrap the light further around the
planet this is looking pretty good we've
got a nice glow going let's add that Sun
bleeding through that you get when
you're viewing the earth from behind
what I do is I use the dot product
between the viewing the Sun but with a
much larger atmosphere and then
calculate the height from the atmosphere
again but this time I'm allowed to go
much higher than the glow and finally we
mix enough Rennell term which just
limits the effect to the edges of the
sphere now in the browser this is
starting to look kind of neat you've got
that horizon Sun effect with lead over
the last thing is that subtle blue haze
as you look closer to the horizon in the
shader code we're just going to do a
straight-up fog calculation the same is
what you would do at ground level on
this line I used the distance from the
camera to the planet run it through an
exponential and modulated by a fernell
term like I did with the Sun therefore
now effect just roughly forces it to get
limited to the edges of the sphere then
I decide the fog color by mixing between
a bluish and a yellowish color depending
on the angle to the Sun now when you
view the planet you've got that faint
haze so depending on what you need
realism cartoonish effects or something
in between you've got options you can
roll it yourself or you can go with some
ultra realistic thing the cool thing
here with our shader is that we can do
whatever we want we can make the
atmosphere 10 times larger than is
possible and it's difficult to get the
same effect using the realistic shader
since it's not physically possible to
have an atmosphere like that like always
source code is available so go ahead and
fork it make sure to hit like and
subscribe and I'll see you next time
Cheers